[Music]
thank you
welcome back to another special episode
of WhatsApp Prof hello Walter Martin
you'll still look exactly the same what
happened you too uh the sun uh moved on
a little bit so we had to move
everything around a bit but we can still
see the fireplace yeah
and we still sit in one of the most
Serene settings
well I never thought that I'd be sitting
and recording what did I
yeah it's always a first a first time
it's open with a word of praying ask God
to lead us our heavenly father we thank
you again for having the privilege of
being in the African bush and recording
a wonderful discussion about
The Plan of Salvation we ask that you
please enlighten our minds and also
bless this discussion in Jesus name amen
amen
we were admonished
to make a deep study of chapter five
of the Book of Revelation Worthy is the
Lamb that was slain
the line of the tribe of Judah
and we
we cannot do justice to it it's not
possible to describe it
[Music]
but we can catch a glimpse
and it will be our study for all
eternity
now when the lamb opened that scroll
and the whole history of redemption was
revealed
and the cost of redemption and the war
and how we are involved and through our
prayers become part and parcel
of all the activities that take place
here on Earth
It's actually an amazing story actually
this chapter forms
The Hub of the whole book of Revelation
and actually if you take it there then
it has to be the Hub of the whole Bible
yes because it's it's the culmination in
the Book of Genesis
is the loss of all things
The Book of Revelation is the
restoration of all things
so whenever you go through what was lost
in in Eden access to the Tree of Life
out of the Garden of Eden robe of
righteousness lost all of those issues
they're all restored in the Book of
Revelation
so they are like the two covers of the
Bible yeah bookends yes and sandwiched
in between them you have the rest it's
actually an amazing story and then
people say that you know
some scribe thought this stuff up and
wrote it down it's it's not even
possible because you can study it for a
lifetime and you will not understand it
true yeah in its fullness in its
fullness
the book is not called The Secret no
it's called the revelation
and whatever is revealed is for us and
for our children
so let's look at part two of the story
now we also read that the ransomed ones
will sing the song of Moses and the lamb
the song of Moses was a song of
redemption that's it from the physical
slavery of Egypt that's it
but the song of the Lamb
that's the one you need to sing and
there's a double connotation so you do
sing the song of Moses but you sing the
song of the lamb as well yes because the
lamp was actually also the one bringing
out the children of Israel out of Egypt
yes so one day all the redeemed will be
able to sing
the song of the Lamb
in Old Testament times they they could
sing it in type
but after the resurrection
of everybody that is part of the first
resurrection
that song Can Be Sung by everyone that
was Redeemed by the blood of the Lamb so
we must have a vision of the future and
of the blessedness of Heaven
because if you lose that you can despair
there is a reward
but before the reward Comes The Blood
The Sweat and the tears
you see I always have in my whole life
wanted something there to look forward
to to make everything that you're doing
bearable yes and I think that's the same
if you keep your eyes on the reward you
act you can bear all this turmoil the
beauty of this race
is that there's not only one winner
stand on the threshold of Eternity and
hear the gracious welcome given to those
who in this life have cooperated with
Christ regarding it a privilege and an
honor
to suffer for his sake
yes we are suffering to an extent but of
course not a fraction of what Christ
suffered for us
but the reward is constantly
there for us to behold
as you as they Unite with the angels
they cast their crowns at the feet of
the Redeemer
exclaiming Worthy is the Lamb that was
slain to receive power and riches and
wisdom and strength and honor and glory
and blessing
honor and glory and power be unto him
that sitteth upon the throne and unto
the lamb forever and ever
so we understand the Plan of Salvation
the cost of salvation
and there is no effort to minimize it in
any way
but to exalt it
we read in the Desire of Ages
but it was not simply the absence of
outward glory in his life
that led the Jews to reject Jesus he was
the embodiment of purity
and they were impure
he dwelt amongst men an example of
spotless Integrity his blameless life
flashed light upon their hearts
his sincerity revealed their insincerity
it made manifest the hollowness of their
pretentious piety
and discovered iniquity in them in its
odious character such a light was
unwelcome
notwithstanding their boasts that under
the lion of the tribe of Judah Israel
should be exalted to preeminence Over
All Nations
they could have borne disappointment of
their ambitious hopes better
than they could bear Christ's reproof of
their sins
and the reproach they felt even from the
presence of his purity
Now isn't it interesting Martin that in
this life if someone does
something good
they sarcastically call him a goody
goody two-shoes
that's it if you are
they also it's a goody goody two shoes
it's also linked to a nerd almost yes so
there are all these these terms that we
apply to those that stand out for being
good that's it
and in a in a setting where people come
together especially youth peer pressure
yes
it doesn't doesn't look kindly upon
someone who is not willing to partake in
a sinful activity that's true it doesn't
matter if it's in high school college
wherever if you are the one trying to do
good you will be the one that's going to
Bear the brunt yes and the interesting
thing is you look back and you say well
uh
I hope I wouldn't have done that but we
constantly do it
so we're just as guilty we would have
probably done worse than they did no for
sure the guarantee we mustn't try and
say okay no Israel
we're not like that we're actually worse
much worse so modern when we look at
this this uh introduction in chapter
five
and the scroll is open then this and the
seals are broken
and you look inside as to what happens
it gives you an entire flow through the
history of the great controversy
and there are certain things that you
need to understand
if you want to unravel the mystery of
what is going on in this earth
and to answer the question Where's God
in all of this
and chapter 5 tells us that he is is
involved from the very beginning to the
point of being slain in order to be
worthy to open the scroll it's so
beautiful you see like we mentioned in
the previous one he's not an absentee
landlord no we must still do that
certainly yes about the absentee
landlord
so it's not surprising to me that two
books are recommended by Jesus
in order for us to get a glimpse of what
this great controversy is about and the
first one of course is the Book of
Daniel
Matthew 24 15 when you therefore shall
see the abomination of desolation
spoken of by Daniel the Prophet stand in
his holy place whoso readeth let him
understand
that tells you that Jesus
recommends The Book of Daniel to our
study study it
you want to know what's going on why the
world is in the state why setting up the
kingdom of God among among the Nations
we did a whole series on that remember
then
study the Book of Daniel know what
happens
if you don't study the Book of Daniel
then you also like those
young people that you want to ostracize
the whole time you're going to ostracize
Christians that actually study the Bible
because they're going to be looking at
the signs and you're going to say Oh no
you're just fear-mongering the old time
all right then it's not only looking at
the signs you have to allow God to
transform you
yeah because you have if you see the
signs that must tell you now you get
ready so how do you get ready you must
say to God help me to change absolutely
and what's the other book Martin
Revelation yes here it is revelation 1
verse 3.
blessed is he that readeth
and they that hear the words of this
prophecy
and keep those things which are written
therein for the time is at hand so here
are two groups he that readeth in other
words those that study the Book of
Revelation start to get a glimpse of
what's going on and want to communicate
it yes and then the second group is
those that hear the words of the
prophecy through the communication and
then start adhering to it and then keep
those things which are written therein
what must you keep well we need to know
right yes what is it that we need to
keep
and what is it that we need to
understand in order to keep it and where
can you find the answer where can you
find the answer so Daniel must be the
key yes and Revelation must be the
revelation of the key that's it okay
so here's another interesting quote when
the books of Daniel and Revelation are
better understood
Believers will have an entirely
different religious experience
have you noticed that
well I can just testify it in my life I
never knew Daniel in a revelation all
you knew about Daniel was when I was in
school we had to draw the the Daniel in
the light in the Lion's Den and those
things but it didn't happen Goliath the
story of Goliath but there was no
typology involved no you didn't have the
prophets prophecy fulfillment and all of
that yes so what we've done is we've
taken the stories which are actually
incredible types of great events yeah
and turned them into children's stories
that's exactly what that happened and
you start preaching about the Book of
Daniel in the Book of Revelation and
people say but why doesn't my church
teach these things
and some become offended and leave
and others hear and take the words of
the prophecy to heart and are changed
so it is absolutely true when she says
when the books of Daniel and Revelation
are better understood Believers will
have an entirely different religious
experience
they will be given such glimpses of the
open Gates of Heaven that heart and mind
will be impressed with a character that
all must develop in order to realize the
blessedness which is to be the reward of
the pure in heart
so Martin it's about transformation
Total Transformation
that's what it's about
and the Lord will bless all who seek
humbly and meekly to understand that
which is revealed in the Revelation how
do we know that it will bless all
because it says there blessed is he he
tells you yes and can you trust him Now
isn't it a strategy of the devil to come
and say this is a sealed book nobody can
understand it so how can you take it to
heart
you cannot because you never read it
nobody if it tells you anything about it
all right so if you take uh cyneticus
the the crown jewel of manuscripts on
which the modern translations are based
they leave it out yeah they also leave
out the first account of Genesis so
the fall and the restoration are gone
those are the wonderful manuscripts on
which to base the word of God the
bookends are gone I cannot even fathom
why some of our theologians don't get it
they must study this issue and see for
themselves
that the received text which has the
Book of Revelation and the Book of
Daniel and all the others in them
yeah and the true ones that they are the
true word of God and you should still do
we should still do that one on the seven
times purified yes that's another one
this book contains so much that is large
with immortality and full of Glory that
all who read and search it earnestly
receive the blessing of those that hear
the words of the prophecy and keep those
things which are written there in one
thing will certainly be understood from
the study of Revelation the connection
between God and his people is close and
decided
there again we don't have an absentee
landlord
a wonderful connection is seen between
the universe of heaven and this world
the things revealed to Daniel were
afterwards complemented by the
Revelation made to John on the Isle of
Patmos these two books should be
carefully studied twice Daniel inquired
how long shall it be to the end of time
and I heard but I understood not then
said I O My Lord what shall be the end
of these things and he said go thy Way
Daniel for the words are closed up and
sealed till the time of the end many
shall be purified and made white and
tried but the wicked shall do wickedly
and none of the wicked shall understand
but the wise shall understand
an understanding of these things does it
serve as a filter yes that's exactly
what it is
because otherwise how do you filter how
do you know this fits in here this fits
in here or is this prophecy or not and
none of the wicked will understand so
what did they do they don't study it and
they don't use the filter and if they
don't use it at all and say it's it's a
closed book nobody can understand it
then then they cannot be amongst the
wise right
no okay now remember
that wisdom comes from God yes so nobody
is exalting himself here because they've
read it no they're just doing what God
Said blessed is he that readeth so get
on with it and start reading it yeah
and if you don't understand it maybe you
should hear what somebody is saying
about it that does understand it
and how did that person understand it by
studying and reading it yes and studying
what other people said about it and you
have a sure word of Prophecy in the
spirit of Prophecy that can help clear
it up
Martin are you going to upset everyone
now again but that's the truth right
that's the truth it's helped me I think
it's helped thousands of millions of
people already
so many will be purified made white and
tried
but the wicked shall do wickedly and
none of the wicked shall understand but
the wise shall understand
but go thy way till the end be for Thou
shalt rest and stand in thy lot at the
end of the days
so here we we are told that there is
more information to come but it wasn't
for the time of Daniel it was for the
time when the kingdom of God should be
set up the Book of Revelation was given
during the Christian era yes and we
discussed the misconception that it's
only given to those living in the last
portion of time no it was given at
Patmos yes it was a revelation then as
it is a revelation now the only
difference
is that as we move along in the Stream
of time we understand more because
things are being fulfilled as we go
along we can see those Signs Now Martin
how do you know that you can see that
science mustn't he be a Watchman of
course
there we go back and if you were a
Watchman what do you do you just sit
there no no once you see these signs you
you become aware of the fact that God is
intimately involved
because he's not only telling you what
is going to happen
he is allowing you to see the
Fulfillment of this
and because it's written historic
continuously
every age within the Christian era can
know where they stand in the Stream of
time not become despairs know when the
end comes that is so true you see the
problem is people become and get fearful
and
trace and all of this when they lose
this connection with the studying and
then applying it to your time correct
now the other thing of course is if you
follow the sequence
then
it applies to every age as we've said
now if you if you're a dispensationalist
and you want to throw everything into
the future and it only applies to the
last people living on this Earth
and then you're still distorted by
leaving out the historic portion and the
Fulfillment thereof you lose everything
you lose the Antichrist here's some
future Airy fairy figure that will arise
everything is gone you see and the
problem with that is you might just sit
and wait for this and miss it yes
and it's all over what happened what
happened yeah what happened what
happened now
so it was the lion of the tribe of Judah
who unsealed the book and gave to John
the revelation of what should be in
these last days now we discussed the
last days that's why this is so
important it refers to the entire
Christian era not just this final
portion as we said you know what I think
that is one of the
first studies you have to do is the last
days latter days study because that's a
foundation yes then you know how to
puzzle in all of these other events
correct now when you read the book of
Revelation you can see but this has
happened this has happened this has
happened this has happened we are now in
this portion so Martin let's put it
bluntly where are we now we are at the
very tippy toes where the implementation
of the mark of the beast is going to
take place
if you don't study it historically
continuously you will not know who the
Beast is correct because you're waiting
for some future events yes you will not
know what the mark of the beast is
because you're waiting for some future
event you'll think it's a computer chip
exactly all salvation by computer chip
no salvation is by the blood of the Lamb
there's a problem even salvation by
injection
you can so get caught up in all of this
yes and the problem is then your eyes
are turned towards the literal
Israel
and you might miss all of the other
things you might miss all of it it's so
important that we study it
so when we read that the wicked shall do
wickedly so do we see that yeah okay
and none of the wicked shall understand
do we see that
then how true this is sin is the
transgression of the law of God and
those who will not accept the light in
regard to the law of God will not
understand the proclamation of the first
second and third Angels messages simple
as that doesn't that show you actually
why there isn't an urgency to proclaim
the Three Angels messages because they
don't understand it
correct
so the Book of Daniel is unsealed in the
Revelation to John and Carries us
forward to the last scenes of this
Earth's history
will our Brethren bear in mind that we
are living amid the Perils of the last
days read Revelation in connection with
Daniel teach these things
itching ears don't want to hear these
things they say bring us love
and that's it that's all we want to hear
and give us smooth messages
I want to come to church because I want
to hear a soothing calming message don't
give me a warning you know what that
actually sounds like you want to go to
church to hear something that feels good
yes and that is dangerous aren't there
many that feel good you never hear the
Book of Daniel or the Book of Revelation
in any of those and you don't get any
that show you how that pertains to signs
so they don't want to see the signs
actually in church correct how do you I
think it's most important not
continually not the only but it must be
balanced all right so Martin if we go to
Revelation chapter 5 we take our Bible
and we go to chapter five
which we have basically read in the
previous
study
and we see that he unseals the book
and that in verse 14 and the four beasts
said amen and the Four and Twenty Elders
fell down and worshiped him that lives
forever and ever the one that was
involved from the beginning
and then he starts unsealing the book
right
so the rest of the Book of Revelation
is what is summed up in that scroll
and here we get a cryptic view of a
sweep through history of what is going
to happen right
and in every stage God is involved and
he divides it up into sevens because
there were seven churches there were
seven periods they are the ones that
received the message what message the
message that was going to be unsealed in
Revelation chapter five and then we go
to chapter six and we read
and I saw when the lamb opened one of
the seals so he's obviously opening a
seal now
and I heard as it were the noise of
Thunder one of the four beasts saying
come and see
and I saw and behold a white horse and
he that sat on him had a bow and a crown
was given unto him and he went forth
conquering to conquer
is this now the lamb that was slain or
the line of the tribe of Judah the lion
of the tribe of Judah all right here is
the battle now between good and evil and
we're going to get a description
of what is going to happen now we're
never going to deal with each one of
these because each one of these would
take a very long time
but in chapter six you have these Riders
the one on the White Horse and then one
on a red horse and then one on a black
horse
and then one on a Pale Horse like death
and of course the horse
is this message going out to the world
and you have a description in chapter
six
of the message the church taking the
message first the pure adulterated
message on the White Horse Christ giving
the revelation of everything that they
had misunderstood right
they'd misunderstood everything they'd
misinterpreted everything they were
basically dispensationalists in their
time and then the irony is that at the
End of Time Satan throws that same
philosophy into into the church and they
grab it hook line and sing It's amazing
every single one that they had to get
purified off is back is back in a
different form but it's the same story
the same nonsense he didn't even have to
concoct up anything else no just throws
it back at you it's right it worked well
for him then why shouldn't worked well
at the end again right
so you have the white host with the pure
unadulterated message
then you have a red horse
which is of course the symbol of blood
and sacrifice the suffering Church how
the church will suffer how eventually it
will become a black horse
and then eventually it will be a dead
horse
so the beautiful other adulterated
message of Salvation will be watered
down to the point of death so that
exists anymore protestantism
Gone Gone
absolutely have we seen this
this has been fulfilled we don't have to
we don't have to go into any further
details there now we're not going to go
into the Book of Revelation but this is
this is basically what the study should
all be about
and in chapter 7 it tells you who the
ones involved are God's children they
will be given Robes of righteousness in
verse 10 he said and cried with a loud
voice saying salvation to our god which
sits upon the throne and unto the lamb
it's the whole story of the unsealing
and it won't be a few people because he
helped beheld the great multitude
standing with the 144
000 and all of these issues in chapter
seven
and then follow the seven trumpets so we
go through the same
time period again and a trumpet is of
course judgment so we need to talk a
little bit about judgment and what is
the Criterium of judgment you know what
because one of the main things that you
hear these days is don't judge me
yes don't judge me okay it's the science
if the Saints can judge Angels how much
more cancer can they judge between
things happening in the church and
should the Judgment be condemning no but
it should be warning yes that's the
difference because there's love in
warning all right someone if you see
is an ant crawling on me
so Martin if you see spiritual formation
creeping into the church and you know
because you've studied that that it's
Jesuit Doctrine
shouldn't you raise your voice you
should raise your voice because you love
the people and don't want them to get
caught up in it so if you see a
technique like neuro-linguistic
programming
should you not raise your voice you have
to if you see false theology starting to
come in which is spiritualistic let's
say manifestations of the spirit which
are not in harmony with the Clause given
to those that obey him shouldn't you
erase your voice like a trumpet
Deliverance prayers
yeah that does Very Yes Deliverance
Ministry what can deliver you from
demonic uh activity isn't it only Christ
I mean what happened to the to those
disciples that tried to get rid of the
correct
so in chapter eight we continue with the
trumpets which we are not dealing with
at this stage
and in chapter 9 and then in chapter 10
you have the unsealing of that
particular scroll
and this Mighty Angel come down from
heaven close to the cloud and a rainbow
was upon his head and his face was as it
were the the Sun and his feet as pillars
of fire and he had in his hand a little
book open and he said his right foot
upon the sea in his left foot upon the
Earth he's the ruler of Heaven and Earth
he is the one who is control in control
of everything that happens here and he
unseals this book
now obviously the sealed book
was that portion of Daniel yes regarding
the 2300 evenings the mornings because
it has to be that way because that's the
only one that's been sealed it was it
says that in Daniel seal this book until
when Until the End yes now the the broad
picture of the Christian era Daniel
didn't understand either
so many of the things he wrote about and
the typologies that we find there you
can only understand in the light of the
New Testament when Christ was has come
but then only understand in in the light
of the great controversy exactly if you
do not have a great controversy
understanding
of the Bible
you will either regard God as a tyrant
yes or you will regard him as a sugar
daddy
that's it because you will not see him
as this great judge
who will judge between the righteous and
the wicked and the Savior he's the lamb
as well he's the lamb that was slain you
will miss that because you won't have
both yes if you don't understand now
sequentially once this scroll has been
unsealed the 2 300 days
that's when the very final battle
between those that understand in other
words see the link between law and Grace
and those that don't understand and what
is that about Revelation chapter 11.
there arises this terrible Beast out of
the bottomless pit in other words the
system
of governance on this Earth that will be
directly opposed to those that represent
God and it is a spiritualistic
organization and it is an organization
not with kings and queens as it was
before
But A system that arises in the
Democratic world
and it's based on spiritism it's based
on mystery it's based on Deception
and it is in a city spiritually called
Sodom in Egypt
it's this whole sick
fullerism
freemasonic systems jesuitism everything
is yes that demoralizes you can see this
this right in the front of our eyes so
this is the system that arises after the
healing of the wound
1798 it's all written here in the Book
of Revelation chapter 11
1798 that mortal wound this Beast is
underground it is working it seemed to
have a mortal wound it is setting up an
occult Empire
and all of those issues that come in and
the nations were angry
and thy wrath is come and the time of
the Dead that they should be judged so
the Judgment of the Dead begins
and then sooner or later we move to the
Judgment of the living where will that
be Martin when the mark of the beast is
being implemented that's it because that
is when the living
have to make a choice yes we are on the
brink of that then follows chapter 12
which gives us a picture of the battle
between Christ's Church and Satan it
gives us a synopsis
and then it ends with those
fascinating words and the dragon was
Wrath with the woman and went to make
war with the remnant of a seed which
keep the Commandments of God and have
the testimony of Jesus Christ so it
describes the very last group on Earth
out of the entire Christian era where
this battle took place in the wilderness
where there was a 1260 year persecution
then arises this group and if you do not
get this if you do not understand that
the remnant keep the Commandments and
hold to the testimony you will miss it
you're going to miss it you're going to
miss it and like we said many times
before you cannot have only one of those
legs correct you have to stand on both
and then you get to Revelation chapter
13 which describes the empires that will
wage the final war against God's people
the Beast out of the Sea and the Beast
out of the Earth now even the reformers
recognized who that was it was the
papacy they didn't understand the United
States yet they didn't understand Fallen
protestantism because it hadn't happened
yet they were still in the part where it
was not Fallen
but this Remnant will understand yeah
and they will know what the issue is it
is the Commandments of God that are at
stake and somehow therefore the mark of
the beast that is also written about
here in Revelation 13 must be associated
with the Commandments otherwise there's
no link and it doesn't make any sense
and then you go to Revelation chapter 14
which is the warning against what these
two beasts are going to do
and uh that's the message of the remnant
and that's the Three Angels messages
all described in perfect sequence
then comes the consequence of not
accepting the message the plagues
chapter 15.
and chapter 16.
and then again you have a synopsis in
chapter 17. as to who the controlling
Powers this woman this church that has
mystery Babylon the great the mother of
harlots and the abomination of the earth
written on a forehead that's her
thinking pattern that's the way in which
he thinks in which he operates that's
why there's a clash of Minds because you
work at the mind of Christ and you've
got the mind of this Babylon
and then comes Revelation chapter 18.
where you get a description of the
degradation that has come into the
churches where Babylon is a unit a Unity
between spiritism Catholicism
and Fallen protestantism now the
spiritualism side incorporates all the
religious systems of the world everyone
that denies the atonement
everyone that denies the deity of Christ
because remember it said worship the
lamb they refuse to worship the lamb
and if we look at the examples that God
has given Humanity of how they are
Fallen
in what state they are if you look at
the the court cases that are going on in
the world yes as to what is happening
within the Beast Within Catholicism
what's happening in the spiritualistic
religions I mean the Dalai Lama was in
the news recently I don't even want to
talk about kissing little boys Etc
God is telling us please look Babylon
has fallen has fallen just Incorporated
in your mind that's you see up until
yeah
we've shown
time and time again how this has all
been fulfilled already yes
and Revelation 19 tells us of the
destruction that is coming
because the king of kings and Lord of
lords will put an end to the system
then we come to Chapters 20 21
and 22 which are eschatological in other
words they tell us about the restoration
of all things that were lost in the Book
of Genesis well that's the heritage
that's what happens when you open the
seals you start to understand the battle
between right and wrong and the
Commandments of God and the mark of the
beast are in opposition to each other
you see when you get to revelation 22
just before entering
Heaven who has the right to enter those
that keep the Commandments of God do you
think Satan hates that verse yeah it's
it no wonder it changes it to something
pathetic in the new translations
all right Martin say if if the law of
God is the issue
because without law
there's no judgment there's no sin
without judgment
there is no consequence
without law there's no sin
and who is the judge Christ is the judge
so let's look at Christ the ultimate
judge John 5 22 for the father judges no
man but has committed all judgment unto
the son
they're all going to have to face him
yeah does that include all those that
rejected him oh for sure those are the
Jewish Nation then what about the Jewish
Nation now the Jewish Nation now and the
spiritual Israel as well all right
are there people within those groups
that can still accept him and become
part of the Israel of God the spiritual
Israel of God every tribe and nation and
tongue let's not forget that
but Christ is the judge
and it's apt that he should be the judge
didn't he buy the price pay the price
for the broken law he was the only one
that could we've heard not in heaven not
on Earth nobody could open that nothing
could open the scroll
and then he says in John 8 verse 16 and
yet if I judge my judgment is true for I
am not alone but I am the father that
sent me
so his judgment is true he's going to
judge a right Worthy is the land or
second Corinthians 5 10. flooring Must
ALL appear before the Judgment seat of
Christ that everyone may receive the
things done in his body according to
that he has done whether it be good or
bad
now when does the Judgment of the Dead
begin
it starts at the end of the 2 300 days
the prophecy in Daniel all right now
Martin because it says there that the
sanctuary will be cleaned yes cleansed
from what
from sin yes it must be cleansed from
the record of the record of sin yes
which was transferred into the sanctuary
now why would it only start in 1844 why
wouldn't it start earlier
the reason is Martin Everybody must have
had the Nations must have had an
opportunity to choose yes
everybody had the opportunity during the
Reformation to know who the Beast is yes
right and everybody should have been
able to discern what the issue is the
Beast is against the Commandments of God
because it changed the Commandments of
God
protestantism in 1844 rejected the
message of the law and therefore aligned
itself with the beast that's it and
therefore it fell it became part of the
system of Babylon of which the Beast is
the false son yeah and it listened to
the lies of the Dragon which has infused
the entire world with its lies that's
what we spoke about lies right correct
you so since 1844 everybody every nation
has had an opportunity to see what was
going to happen therefore the Judgment
of the Dead begins then yes and it
continues until the Sunday law is
proclaimed yes because then
the living has a choice to make just as
the other ones had a choice to make
before it and God's people also have to
make a choice oh yes God's people have
to make a choice and the interesting
thing is
that choice will determine whether they
receive the Seal of God
or whether they do not receive the Seal
of God if they receive the Seal of God
they become part of the loud cry
that's and then it will grow that all
out Christ and they will join with
others and what is the loud cry Babylon
has fallen has fallen she has become a
house of demons and every unclean and
detestable Bird that's just a portion of
the Lord Christ exactly it has to be
coupled to the mark of the beast yes
which is do not accept a false set of
norms and standards except those that
God introduced that is the issue the
Bible also says that judgment begins at
the house of God yes because it has to
begin there because that has to
determine who will give the loud crying
exactly so there's a shaking that has to
take place yes a purification if you
want correct
in Isaiah 33 verse 22 we read for the
Lord is our judge the Lord is our Lord
giver and it's very clear oh yeah
only the one that gave the law
is able to interpret the law and to
apply the law
and has the right to do it because he
paid the price for the transgressed law
that's it
the Lord is our King
he will save us so we have all the
titles here is Judge his law Giver
and his King
and you have to accept the package deal
you can't pick and choose that's so
important there's not one you cannot
stand only I just want him as king but
not a savior and I cannot have him only
a savior and the lamb but not as king
correct
or Revelation 14 7 saying with the loud
voice fear God and give glory to him for
the hour of his judgment is come
worship him that made Heaven and Earth
the sea and The Fountains of water this
is such a deep verse because it tells
you the hour of his judgment has come
it's already now this message only went
out of the 1844. correct so the Judgment
began in 1844 Judgment of the Dead
then it says worship Him who made Heaven
and Earth that's the Seal of God yeah
it's in the fourth Commandment finished
because that one says why the seventh
day was instituted so the mark of the
beast must be the antithesis of this
because the mark of the beast deals with
worship because they worship the Beast
who receive the mark of the beast but
you have to worship God who made so the
other one says no you have to worship me
that's it he's actually the creator of
the other day he's the creator of the
other day the first day of the week
so what is the standard of judgment
well it's the law
and basically you have to judge between
the word of God and the word of Satan
that's it too those are the two like we
always said and then there issues
between the two Yeah Tuesday this day
Jews either one or the either not in
between exactly
John 12 48 he that rejecteth me
receiveth not my words you see
basically what it's all about
and then he has one that judges him the
word that I have spoken the same shall
judge him in the last days
remember we in the previous one said
Goliath's head was chopped off by this
his own sword that's it that's his word
but what he said and what he believed he
was judged
and the head was crushed
and that will be the same with everybody
that will be exactly the same so what is
the standard Martin you're feeling or
the word oh the word
what did Martin Luther say what did the
reformation say
Salah
the word is the one that will judge you
does the word contain the Ten
Commandments yes the law of God
here are there that keeps the
Commandments versus those that do not
keep the Commandments here are those
that honor the Seal of God worship him
that made which is the Sabbath versus
those that do not honor it in fact
the fourth Commandment in Roman
Catholicism honors your works because
you
partake of a Sacrament you do the work
you get the grace
where in actual fact that which was
instituted for your education should
change your character that's the thing
The Total Transformation yes and the
thing is if you actually read in the
great controversy
in Luther's time he also had the problem
about a false Revival Revival based on
feeling on the spirit do we have a whole
religious system in the world that bases
its theology on
feeling yes that's why we must test the
spirits
samadhan that is why we read in
Revelation chapter 4 11 Thou Art Worthy
O Lord to receive glory and honor and
Power
for thou has created all things and for
thy pleasure they are and were created
so he's worthy because he is the Creator
and he is the Redeemer the lamb that was
slain
can we see that this is coupled to the
fourth Commandment absolutely creation
yes you cannot uncouple it
Second Kings 19 15 and Hezekiah prayed
before the Lord and said O Lord God of
Israel which dwelleth between the
cherubim Thou Art the god even thou
alone of all the kingdoms of the earth
that has made Heaven and Earth this is
the acknowledgment
the memorial of creation
that's it you can't get away from it now
you go do in Revelation it takes you
back to that one it's a theme
Isaiah 37 16 O Lord of hosts God of
Israel that dwelleth between the
cherubim didn't we read about that in
Revelation chapter five
Thou Art the god even thou alone of all
the kingdoms of the earth thou Hast made
Heaven and Earth
this is a recurring theme throughout the
Bible he's the owner
but he had to purchase his own creation
amazing he is he's the landlord but he
had to purchase it again with his blood
Revelation 5 9 and they sung a new song
saying Thou Art Worthy to take the book
and to open the seals thereof for thou
was slain and has redeemed us to God by
thy blood out of every Kindred tongue
and people and Nation there goes all
hypocrisy
racism Everything is dispensationalism
Everything Is Gone is gone
Daniel 7 22 until the Ancient of Days
came and judgment was given to the
Saints of the most high and the time
came that the Saints possessed the
kingdom Martin this is a verse as we
have discussed many times that is so
perverted in other
translations and in other views
judgment was not given in favor of the
Saints here no judgment was given to the
Saints do you not know that you will
judge Angels we've dealt with this
that is why I love this King James
version rendering because it is a direct
translation of what God Said with no
interposition of human thinking the
thing is you destroy that the reward of
The Testament
that the inheritance if you change that
because that's part of the inheritance
is co-rulership rulership you are part
of the throne you are in the throne you
are pardoned parcel of it and judgment
is handed of them over to them not that
they judge because all judgment has been
given to Christ it's the Judgment of
verification that's it where you say
Worthy is the Lamb all your judgments
are true everything was according to
your righteousness and the lies of the
devil are exposed
and then Martin they can sing a song and
you can read it in Psalms 149.
of course when you start singing the
song of the lamb as well then there's a
new Nuance yeah
but basically it says Praise You the
Lord sing unto the Lord a new song
and his praise in the congregation of
the Saints let Israel rejoice in him
that made him there's that recurring
theme of creation Creation in you I mean
he says he newly creates in you as well
if you are part of doing The Total
Transformation he creates a new view
correct let the children of Zion be
joyful in their King let them praise His
name in the dance let him sing praises
unto him with the Timberland heart for
the Lord
taketh pleasure in his people he will
beautify the meek with salvation
can you see the involvement of the
Throne of heaven with Humanity
let the Saints be joyful in glory let
them sing aloud upon their beds let the
high praises of God be in their mouth
and a two-age sword in their hand
that's the word of God right yes but it
cuts both ways it cuts the way that
you're slicing it and it cuts back
towards you it has to change to it short
and that's the opposite from Goliath's
sword that cut off his own head this one
actually this cuts and redeems you if
you are adhering to what it says yes
to execute vengeance upon the Heathen
and Punishment upon the people to bind
their kings with chains and their nobles
with Fetters of iron to execute upon
them the Judgment written this honor
have all his Saints praise ye the Lord
judgment was given to the Saints and to
be part of that throne and the final
overthrow of the LIE this is the honor
of the Saints
it's your reward
what about Isaiah 32 verse 1 Behold a
king shall reign in righteousness and
princes shall rule in judgment well the
princess Martin the co-rulers the
redeemed of God you know this theme is
pervasive in the entire word of God
Ezekiel 44 24.
and in controversy they shall stand in
judgment and they shall judge it
according to my judgments isn't that
clear he judges all judgment is given
unto him the Saints verify the judgment
and they Proclaim that he is worthy to
be the judge because he has created all
things and by him they exist and they
shall keep my laws and my statues in all
my assemblies and they shall hallow my
sabbaths so Martin are we far-fetched
when we say that the law and the Sabbath
will be the issue of the in order to
bring about the final decision about who
you worship now it started off in
creation God said at the seventh day do
this because I'm the Creator and in the
end he will say okay now you're going to
be judged do you accept me as this
Creator and Redeemer yes because you
have to accept him as your lamb that was
slain you have to accept him as the lion
of the tribe of Judah you have to accept
him as your king and you have to accept
him as your God that's it now I beseech
you says 1 Corinthians 1 10 Brethren by
the name of our Lord Jesus Christ us
that they all speak the same thing and
that there be no division amongst you
but that you be perfectly joined
together in the same mind and in the
same judgment
so here is the issue
how do you come into harmony with God
you have to study his requirements
and is given the testimony of Jesus to
the remnant which it says so in
Revelation 12 17.
and this can enable you to come into
Harmony and of one mind yeah and then
you will be able to discern and be part
of this judgment we've mentioned this
also many times before but if you want
to have that Oneness of mind that same
Unity that will be based on studying the
spirit of Prophecy yes and taking it to
heart not just studying implementing it
yes
but it also has to be a double-edged
sword it has to create a change within
you because head knowledge alone won't
do it if your fruits don't tell of what
you have changed there's nothing no
that's why we're reading 1 John 4 17.
herein is our love made perfect
that we may have boldness in the day of
judgment because as he is so are we
in this world you have to become
christ-like
that's it you started off with Total
Transformation
if we don't become christ-like
how can we then enjoy heaven
yeah
so modern judgment is handed to the
Saints right let's just read a few more
verses just to you know try and paint a
complete picture
proverbs 31 verse 9 open thy mouth judge
righteously and plead the cause of the
poor and the needy does God ask us to
judge righteously yes yes he does
what will be the standard that we must
use the Commandments
Isaiah 1 17 learn to do well seek
judgment relieve the oppressed and judge
the fatherless plead for the Widow
does he ask us to judge righteousness
you know what the problem is you've got
do what thou Wilt but that's changed now
so don't judge me don't judge me as I 5
3 and now are inhabitants of Jerusalem
and Men of Judah judge I pray you
between me and my Vineyard
have we got the right to judge between
what Christ says and what the church
says we do we actually should do it it
says there judge between me and my
Vineyard which one's right didn't his
Vineyard reject him yes
and isn't the present one rejecting him
too that's why accepting the papal
decrees and the mark of the beast they
are now I just want to make clear again
this judgment is accompanied by love
always
because God does not judge without love
no no we do sometimes and we shouldn't
yeah one Corinthians 6 3 now you're not
that we shall judge Angels how much more
things that pertain to this life are we
supposed to judge yeah
one Corinthians 6 4 if then you have
judgments of things pertaining to this
life set them to judge who are least
esteemed in the church
or I speak to your shame it is so that
there is not a wise man amongst you no
not one that shall be able to judge
between his Brethren so God definitely
wants us to judge yeah between what is
right and what is wrong and the standard
of judgment always remains the word and
his law that's it and then help each
other through it
that's why in Revelation 20 verse 4 we
read and I saw Thrones and they sat upon
them and judgment was given unto them
whose judgment was given unto the Saints
so the Judgment was complete because it
was handed over to them here were my
judgments now you can determine whether
it was fair of me to exclude this one
that one or this organization and that
organization and these individuals was
it fair or was it not fair you see I
knew that there was some method in The
Madness of becoming an auditor
because I'm going to be an auditor in
heaven of the Judgment books you're
going to order the books yes
so it was handed to them and I saw the
souls of them that were beheaded for the
witness of Jesus and for the word of God
interesting that there are these two
things you have to witness yeah
and it has to be based on the word of
God
so if you if you believe the word of God
you're already judged visit what is the
what does the intellectual professor of
theology or the intellectual professor
of evolution say to one who believes the
word as it stands
he's a fool he's a fool I remember the
professor of theology
telling me
that I cannot do a thesis on creation
because we don't believe in creation
and when I said well can I do one on the
true Messiah versus the false Messiah he
said to me which Messiah are you
speaking about and I asked him is there
more than one
he said yes of course
so well if you think that greater
tunberg has been given an honorary
doctorate in theology it doesn't that
tell you something it tells me something
yes she's received one in Earth Worship
in guyanism
so that we're beheaded for the witness
of Jesus and for the word of God
and which had not worshiped the Beast so
will not follow the dictates of a fallen
Church on this Earth
neither the image they will not follow
Fallen protestantism which says the law
has been negated it's taken away but we
will keep people law and we'll attach it
to Gaia and we'll have a climate law and
we'll have a sport law we must talk
about sport that's another one we must
talk about
again the religion of sport
neither had received the mark upon their
forets or in their hands they hadn't
been induced to thinking like this nor
had they acted upon it
and they lived and reigned with Christ
the thousand years that's when that
judgment takes place
I have a question Martin
can man question the Judgment of God
yes yes
he says come let us reason together
right and then you have the story of
Abraham that intercedes for Sodom
and we read it in Genesis Chapter 18 but
let's read 23 and Abraham Drew near
that's very interesting
and said wilt thou also destroy the
righteous with the wicked yeah isn't he
asking he's questioning the Judgment yes
and then Genesis 18 25 he says shall not
the judge of all the Earth do right
so you know we have the right to ask him
excuse me
why is so and so not here
or Isaiah will will quietly draw near
and Whisper into Jesus's ear and say
I don't want to be you know funny now
Lord but what's Manasseh doing here
what's he doing here
and the Lord says to him Isaiah just
check the book of record here
and he sees the repentance of Manasseh
and the grace of God in restoring him
and what will be his reaction his
reaction will be true and righteous or
your judgments and he will go to
Manasseh and put his arms around him and
say I'm so glad you are here and it will
be joy and it will be joy and tears will
roll down both their cheeks and Manasseh
will say I'm so sorry for what I did to
you
but we have the right question
and that's why judgment is handed to the
Saints
so basically modern if you don't believe
the word of God then what do you believe
well the LIE
and who is the author and the father of
the LIE Satan Satan himself
so Joshua 24 says and if it seems evil
unto you to serve the Lord choose ye
this day and you will serve whether the
gods which your father served that were
on the other side of the flood or the
gods of the amorites in whose land you
dwell
but as for me and my house we will serve
the Lord there's a choice
acts 7 42 then God turned and gave them
up to worship the hosts of Heaven
as it is written in the book of the
prophets O ye House of Israel have ye
offered to me slain beasts and
sacrifices by the space of 40 years in
the wilderness
yea ye took up the Tabernacle of malach
and the star of your God
figures which he made to worship them
and I will carry you away Beyond Babylon
did they make a choice yes will you
judge between the vineyard and Christ
or 1 Kings 18 21 and Elijah came unto
all the people and said how long how to
between two opinions if the Lord be God
follow him but if Baal then follow him
and the people answered him
not a word did they have to make a
choice yes and unfortunately silence is
also a choice yes that they have to
choose between him and his Vineyard
what was the vineyard teaching them the
lies the lie about worship right his
church was leading them into battle
worship Elijah said no I'm the only one
left God said no no no relax there are
still seven thousand but as for these
let's just get this over with what
happened to the Bible priests
they were destroyed isn't that a type
yes okay oh it's a it's a
a sad but beautiful type Deuteronomy 32
17 they sacrificed unto Devils
that's pretty straightforward right that
doesn't go off good well if you say that
today okay so basically Martin if you
remove the law
then who are you worshiping Satan
nowhere we read about fence Setters that
you can be undecided so imagine if you
take away the law
you automatically take away the
atonement if you take away the atonement
you take away the lamb you can sing as
many songs as you like about the lamb
but you're not worshiping the lamb
you're worshiping the devil that's it
okay
so the worshiped Devils they sacrificed
unto devils and not to God
to Gods whom they knew not to New Gods
that came newly up whom your fathers
feared not
it's very plain
2 Corinthians 11 15 and you ordained
them priests for the high places and for
the devils and for the calves which he
had made talking about the Kings
of Israel they worship devils we're
doing exactly the same in the world
today
Psalms 106 37 yea they sacrificed their
sons and their daughters unto devils
it's a choice is it
there's another one
Corinthians 10 20 and I say that the
things with the Gentiles sacrifice
they sacrificed to devils
it's hard words you know what the
problem is if you like I just said
earlier if you say these things people
get so upset with you yes because how
can you do this how can you judge people
correct didn't we just see we have to
but the holy spirit is only given to
them that obey him
acts five
and not to God and I would not that you
should have fellowship with devils
and Revelation 9 20 and the rest of the
men which were not killed by these
plagues yet repented not of their Works
to of their hands
that they should not worship devils and
Idols of gold and silver and brass and
stone and wood which neither can see nor
hear nor walk
that's the choice that has to be made
this is what the Book of Revelation is
all about you have to worship God not
Devils that's the call of the first
Angel's message
Hebrews 1 6 and again when he bringeth
in the firstborn begotten into the world
he says and let all the angels of God
worship him is he God yes if all the
Angels Have To Worship Him
and then he is God
do we have to worship Him how do you
acknowledge Him
through worship and keeping his
Commandments
and then follows Martin The Three Angels
message of Revelation 14. fear God and
give glory to him we're not going to go
through them again this is the Crux of
the matter the final warning to humanity
and this is what it is based on and if
they refuse then the smoke of their
torment Ascend us forever and ever
in other words they'll be gone forever
and ever they will burn they will be
burnt to ashes under your feet and the
consequences will be those are the
consequences
and Revelation 15 verse 4 says who shall
not fear thee O Lord and glorify thy
name for thou only odd holy for all
nations shall come and worship before
thee for thy judgments are made
manifest modern that is the unsealing of
the scroll
that is the battle between good and evil
these are the issues that are involved
and the final outcome is clearly
described in this book and now it is for
us to bring the message and for everyone
else to make a choice amen am I may we
make the correct ones yes let's pray
Heavenly Father
we want to thank you
that the lion of the tribe of Judah
as the lamb slain from the foundation of
the world
was worthy to open the scroll
and thank you that we have the scroll we
have the entire history of the battle
between good and evil
we have the entire history of the
Splendor and the glory and then the
terrible fall
of the church that is supposed to
represent you your Vineyard
and the final message of Warning by
those that keep the Commandments and
have the testimony and the faith of
Jesus
that they should not beat partakers of
the sins of the world at the time of
judgment have come that they must
worship the one who made the heavens the
Earth the Sea and the Springs of water
and that we must not partake of the
spirit of the Beast
Lord help us to bring this message and
the loud cry that Babylon Has Fallen so
that the world can understand what the
battle is all about
and above all Lord Open Hearts and Minds
to make the right choice to choose the
lamb that was slain
so that the lion of the tribe of Judah
can redeem them in Jesus name amen amen
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you